so there's a new study which finds that
legalizing cannabis also known as
marijuana pot weed
etc
legalizing cannabis lowers demand for
prescription drugs
and this really shouldn't come as a
surprise to us i mean if we want to
focus in just narrowly on this we know
that sometimes
uh cannabis can be a substitute for
pharmaceutical uh anxiety medication we
can know that cannabis we know that
cannabis is sometimes a workable
substitute for big pharma sleep
medication we know that cannabis can be
a replacement for opiate
pain medication there's a long list and
it's not the idea that cannabis is this
panacea cure-all substance but we know
from good studies
that in many cases
you can find a cannabis-based
alternative for a variety of different
symptoms where you might reach for some
other kind of medication now whether we
say it's better to reach for the
cannabis or not i'm not even evaluating
that in this segment it actually doesn't
matter for our purposes but the point is
we know that there is this very
um the the tentacles
of opposition to cannabis legalization
come from a number of different areas
and now we have a new study which points
very specifically to this aspect of it
there's a good piece in the hill about
this legalizing marijuana lowers demand
for prescription drugs study fines the
reductions in drug utilization that we
find could lead
could lead to significant cost savings
for state medicaid programs the results
also indicate an opportunity to reduce
the harm that can come with the
dangerous side effects associated with
some prescription drugs one researcher
said i encourage you to read about the
study and the details about the study
but as i pointed out they found a
decline in the volume of prescriptions
targeting pain depression anxiety sleep
psychosis and seizures in states that
have legalized recreational use so what
are the kind of important takeaways as
we think about this as a political issue
it makes a lot of sense that lots of
different elements would want to keep
cannabis illegal or at least not
recreationally legal
it increases profits
in a number of different areas i'm only
going to mention a few there's probably
more so big pharma if you have
widespread recreational cannabis
legalization
big pharma profits would likely go down
in those places private prisons we've
said before you know private prisons are
not as big in the united states as some
people think i think the last uh
study i saw says private prison inmates
are nine or eleven percent
of federal inmates
and like
zero percent or close to zero at the
state level i believe that that's true
but to some degree
when you have more reasons why someone
might be imprisoned that's good for
private prison profits for sure
the bail bonds industry
if you take something that's currently
against the law
and you make it legal fewer people will
demand the service of bail bonds
lawyers right i mean to some degree if
you eliminate a crime you eliminate the
need for lawyers to defend people
against charges for that crime
we also know that cannabis legalization
lowers demand for alcohol
i don't know but i wonder if it reduces
the demand for cigarettes maybe i don't
know enough about the cigarette piece to
be able to say for sure and i'm sure
that i'm missing many here uh in my
discussion of this so
this is both why on the one hand a lot
of these different industries would want
to keep cannabis illegal oh sorry i
forgot a major one
police departments
seizures both of drugs but also of cash
associated with the dealing of cannabis
etc that's also another big aspect of
this uh police departments local police
departments receiving significant monies
as a result of cannabis not being
recreationally legal or even
decriminalized at all so on the one hand
you that's why big pharma
would oppose cannabis legalization but
at the same time
it seems big pharma realizes that the
writing is sort of on the wall and big
pharma has also been pursuing patents
related to cannabis so it's like they
don't like it until they take over the
business and can monetize it at which
point they really like it none of this
should surprise us and if you've been
following the political discussion
around cannabis for any period of time
or for more than a decade as we have on
the show
you would um understand
the
incongruency and we could really call it
a double standard or hypocrisy that
exists compared to so many different
things when you look at the schedule one
federal designation of cannabis
up there with the most damaging and
addicting substances of no medicinal
value when hold on a second we we know i
mean the study
big pharma concedes
that legal cannabis is a threat to their
profits because it is of medicinal value
without calling it a panacea of course
uh you know that the schedule one
designation doesn't make any sense
uh and we've talked about all of these
aspects before so here is another one
and i still on this you know there was a
period i remember early in the show's
history
where we started to see
gay marriage legalization in one state
in another state in a third state in a
fourth state
and at the time i remember conversations
with the team and with guests
there was a certain feeling of
inevitability
that it's hard to imagine 10 years down
the line
that gay couples lesbian couples
wouldn't be able to get married anywhere
in the united states and indeed
ultimately it happened i have a similar
feeling of inevitability to some degree
when it comes to cannabis i don't know
how soon we're going to see recreational
legalization nationally i don't know
about that
but there's a sense of inevitability
that we are heading in the direction at
least a federal decriminalization i
don't know when it will come
but there's that same sort of sense that
i have
if you disagree
uh let me know i'd be interested in
hearing from you
we have to talk about books i like books
i like reading and i say more books the
better as a general rule doesn't mean
every book is appropriate for every
setting or every situation okay we've
talked about that before but the real
question i have is
according to these right wingers
is banning books good or bad and you
might be saying well david no it's
obviously good or it's obviously bad but
it's really not so clear because we see
both perspectives from this modern
american book burning
contingent that exists uh in the right
uh as i talked to you about not that
long ago
book ban efforts have hit their highest
levels in at least 20 years and it's the
right not the left that's doing this we
looked at this article uh must have been
when is this article even from about a
month ago we lo we did the story a
couple weeks ago three three weeks ago
or so that book ban efforts led by the
american right wing are at their highest
level in 20 years now what we mean by
book bans differs in different
situations in some cases what we're
talking about is a movement by the right
to ban a book from being used in school
sometimes it's novels sometimes it's
certain history books etc they're not
necessarily calling for the books to not
be published or for the books to be
against the law
but they certainly want to cancel a
teacher's ability to say here's a book
that i want to teach from they don't
want to give teachers that opportunity
in other cases it's confusion about what
it even means and we're going to get to
that in a moment but
we know that the efforts to ban books
are at multi-decade highs led by the
american right wing
uh so they must be in favor of the book
bans right
well
apparently not
because remember the dr seuss situation
this was now about a year ago well it's
actually hard to believe it's been a
year but it has been a year
where
the publisher of dr seuss books said hey
you know what
some of these books this is our review
we're a private business we can make the
decisions that are right for us
we believe that some of these dr seuss
books they have elements that are not
really sensitive to modern cultural
sensitivities we're a private business
we're a publisher and we think it's not
good for business to keep publishing
some of these so we're not going to keep
printing more copies we're not burning
the books we're not saying the books
should be against the law we're not
saying people can't read them we just
think continuing to print these
particular books is no longer in line
with what's best for us and the right
went crazy saying oh my god the left is
banning the books they're canceling dr
seuss it's terrible always allow the
books everywhere everywhere everywhere
oh okay so they're against i guess
limitations on books
except now
as we talked about yesterday and as
we've been talking about for several
months they seem fine banning books
when it's books that they don't like
when it's history books that tell
the real story as far as we know at this
time
of uh slavery
of racial discrimination of all sorts of
different aspects of history all of a
sudden the very same right-wingers who
were saying they're canceling dr seuss
they say we got to get these books the
hell out of here
we now are learning about this new
effort in florida
to
reject math textbooks because they
contain so-called critical race theory
although
ron desantis and other floridians have
not been able to provide a single
substantive example of where such
critical race theory exists so
i guess the question of
is banning books good or bad
the answer is well i guess it depends on
their mood
i guess it depends on which books
i guess it depends on who's doing it and
why
and it's a very similar phenomenon with
protests if you're protesting police
brutality if you're protesting in favor
of uh black lives matter if you're
protesting in defense of george floyd
well then these protests are dangerous
to law enforcement and we've got to back
the blue and they're
all violent and looting and all these
different things but if you're
protesting against
joe biden being the president and
getting sworn in because he was elected
on january 6 well then you're doing the
right thing and you're being treated
very unfairly by everybody and what
about back the blue because they beat up
some cops oh no no we don't care about
that all of a sudden because they were
protesting against the certification of
the election oh so i guess it's not
really so simple and the principle here
is the one i've been telling you about
now for years
which is
they don't even really care about their
own stated principles they stake out
apparent principles
to justify
the end results that they already want
if their principles all of a sudden
would point to
actually black lives matter can protest
actually you shouldn't ban these books
then they change their principles
because their principles are no longer
convenient to their pre-existing end
goals and this is the theme we've been
following for years at this point in
time um i don't think this is going to
stop anytime soon and in particular
because they don't really want to engage
on what should climate policy be
what should policy be on renewable
sources of energy what should the top
tax rate be they can only engage
completely superficially taxes are bad
green new deal is bad
because they are unwilling or unable to
engage substantively on those issues
they're going to keep pushing this stuff
and it works i don't want to be a broken
record but part of why glenn younkin won
the virginia gubernatorial race is
because this stuff works i will ban
teaching of critical race theory who's
teaching it well it doesn't matter i
will ban it wow i'm going to vote for
this guy
this stuff works
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is funded by you
we we really depend on you to produce
this show
we have a membership program at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day for the people that sign up there
we've got this show you're listening to
or watching now but then we do another
show for our members we also offer
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show every day and we offer them
up to six hours before the show is
released to everybody else so there's
some great perks to membership i would
really love it if you signed up at
joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code wow22
to sign up at a discount i don't care at
what price level you get involved if you
want to do the big boy the level 4
yearly membership we welcome that if you
want to get a monthly membership with a
discount code for under 2 bucks a month
we welcome it we welcome all levels of
support the point here is how many
people can we get involved that's the
most important thing and you can sign up
at joinpackman.com all right this is a
wild story that some people are actually
finding themselves sort of sort of
triggered by there's a msnbc
tv analyst named malcolm nance and he's
been around for a while now
uh former uh intelligence guy kind of a
well well-known in the space at this
point in time
he has actually joined the fight in
ukraine he is he is fighting in ukraine
at least to some extent against the
russian invasion and this is fascinating
and without becoming sort of like a
war porn
uh
uh
advocate um
this is someone putting their sort of
money or or their time at least
where their mouth is uh there's a report
from the denver gazette msnbc analyst
malcolm nance reveals he joined the
fight in ukraine
malcolm nance and author and former
military intelligence analyst
appeared for an interview monday with
msnbc host joy reid who said he was at a
secure location
nance was dressed in military garb and
holding a rifle said he joined ukraine's
foreign legion about a month ago to fend
off what he called russia's war of
extermination
i have a little bit of that interview
let's check it out and you will notice
if you're watching malcolm nance is
wearing uh i don't want to use the wrong
term i don't i guess we'll just call it
military garb and he's holding a weapon
as well joining me now from a secure
location in western ukraine is malcolm
nance executive director of the terror
asymmetrics project he's fighting with
the international legion of territorial
defense of ukraine and malcolm um we
just watched that video of you and ali
rusi was attempting to interview you for
us
to get more information on what you're
doing we saw those cruise missiles fly
overhead so explain to us um
why you are there and what you are doing
well as you know i spent quite a bit of
time here in the pre-war period
and when the invasion happened i had
friends who were in donetsk who were in
the ukrainian army who were writing to
us and telling us we're not going to
survive tonight we've been hit 500 times
uh you know these graduates at defense
language institute these were my friends
and you know as the more i saw of the
war going on the more i thought i'm done
talking all right it's time to take
action here so uh about a month ago i
joined the international uh legion here
in ukraine and i am here to help this
country
fight you know what essentially is a war
of of its of extermination this is an
existential war and russia has bought it
to these people and they are mass
murdering civilians and there are people
here like me who are here to do
something about it so there's some on
the left who have reacted to this by
saying oh god the glorification of
malcolm nance
doing this
is uh war porn it's glorifying violence
it's pro-war to say what a great thing
that malcolm nance is doing
i don't see it that way
is 61.
he could just stay with his cushy msnbc
gig and i'm guessing he does consulting
and speaking and all these different
things
he is at least theoretically i mean
listen you know if you come back and you
tell me nance isn't really exposed to
any danger this is all a setup he put on
a uniform and he's there but he's in
like the part of the country where
nothing's going on okay let me like
listen there's no evidence of that but
i'm sure someone would make that claim
but at least in theory he is he's there
and he's putting himself in at risk
and he believes that this is a war of
aggression by russia against ukraine
that ukraine is fighting a defense of
war
and along those lines if you're in a
position to have to defend your country
uh and by proxy that's what malcolm
nance is doing you're not pro-war
because you say wow he's actually in the
real world doing the thing that many of
us just sit in front of microphones and
say
this is the side that i'm on for lack of
a better term so seeing this and saying
that the other aspect to this is there's
a there's a big
i don't want to call it big there's a
loud movement
on the online left
which
is very
just
black and white antagonistic
against any government or intelligence
agency and they haven't liked malcolm
nance for a long time they say this guy
is the epitome of the sometimes they'll
even use the term deep state or of the
establishment intel that got iraq wrong
and they got this wrong and they got
that wrong and so they see this as the
sort of worst of the worst
meshing of american intelligence
and
um corporate media
uh and pro-war democrats or whatever you
want to say i i really just don't see it
that way i am as anti-war as anybody
else
this is a defensive war for ukraine and
he is at least to some degree
putting his money where his mouth is
it's not a glorification of war like a
war movie i just don't see it that way
if you disagree and you think that is
what this malcolm nance thing is then i
want to hear from you
we've been extensively covering the
growing civil war within the republican
party the battle lines are not super
clear but to some degree at least at the
very top level the battle lines are
pro-trump and anti-trump republicans and
one really interesting figure
in that
is florida governor ron desantis and
he's interesting because it's not
exactly clear which side he's on and
what i mean by that is early in the
pandemic when the failed former
president donald trump was still the
actively failing president donald trump
ron desantis and trump were very buddy
buddy early in the pandemic desantis
refused to close and or very quickly
opened major events sporting events all
sorts of different things trump pointed
to desantis as a guy doing the right
thing and they were very buddy-buddy
over time it started to become clear
that there was at least some appetite
from within the republican party for an
alternative to trump and while the
alternative that they seem to be seeking
is not
you know mitt romney
uh it's it is ron desantis to some
degree
ron desantis has increasingly been
thought of as an alternative to trump
now it's weird because desantis is
almost like trump to the nth degree
desantis has a lot of the same terrible
ideas of trump the same political
instincts of trump but he's more
competent and he's less cartoonish and
he's probably more dangerous if he gets
the opportunity to be president of the
united states but so kind of by default
there started to be this well will it be
trump 2024 or will it be desantis 2024
and this has really triggered donald
trump to the point where we now have
multiple reports we've told you about
where trump is reportedly furious that
for example when desantis has asked hey
will you run in 2024 desantis doesn't go
oh absolutely not it's trump's for the
taking desantis hasn't said that and
there are numerous reports that trump
and people around him are upset about
that this brings us to this past weekend
at mar-a-lago
and at mar-a-lago uh roger stone who was
a guest on this program and was
was ultimately convicted and then
pardoned and he's a friend of trump okay
whatever roger stone was filmed at
mar-a-lago and he goes up to trump and
he says ron desantis is a piece of s
and
that video was initially kind of cut so
you don't really see what trump's
reaction is
now the fuller video has been released
i'm going to play it for you now of
course if you're listening you're not
going to know what trump does but the
big deal that's being made is trump nods
when roger stone tells him ron desantis
is a piece of s let's take a look at the
video let's take a listen to the video
[Music]
roger
[Music]
how can i not see god
[Music]
okay
so listen
this is not like the big smoking gun
that trump has declared declared you
know open season on ron desantis or
anything like it there's also we we
can't ignore that there's really strange
kind of like godfather vibes uh at the
start of the first godfather movie
incredible movie uh by the way uh when i
sometimes when i mention the godfather
people email saying i'm glorifying
violence because it's a violent film no
it's just a great film uh the scene at
the wedding where everybody is kind of
making their pilgrimages and saying
hello thank you godfather i have a favor
i need this i need that oh you're so
great there's a similar vibe to it
that's developed at mar-a-lago with
people coming and making their
pilgrimages to trump but putting that
aside um there is no question that
donald trump is now hostile to ron
desantis and it's increasingly clear
that voters are aware that there is an
alternative to donald donald trump so
we've looked at these numbers before and
they continue to improve slightly in ron
desantis favor if you go to
predicted.org where you can bet on who
will be you can bet on almost anything
they'll take your action but one of the
things is you can bet on who will be the
2024 republican nominee
uh last time we looked at this it was
39.29
39
believed it would be trump and 29
believed it would be desantis that was
the closest it had been since the start
of uh you know of the discussion of
2024. it is now tightened up a little
bit more where now it is 38.30 this is
based on money betting these aren't
polls but if you look at how people are
betting
38 percent now believe trump will be the
nominee and 30 believe it will be ron
desantis there is no way trump's not
aware of these numbers
and desantis is quickly gaining ground
on donald trump this is the tightest
that it's been now if you look at actual
polling the most recent polling i found
is from a couple months ago actually
almost three months ago
and there
you had trump at 57 percent
this was a harvard caps harris poll it
had three months ago trump was at 57
percent among republicans
and desantis and pence each had 12. now
that's three months ago the numbers may
well have tightened since then but there
is
let me put it a different way
it is not a foregone conclusion that if
there is a contested 24 primary and
trump runs and desantis runs that trump
runs away with it there
desantis has growing support
and increasingly people believe
he has a real shot and that's the first
step in having a shot people believing
you have a shot it becomes a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy so expect that
it will get delightfully ugly if both
trump and desantis keep pointing towards
i may indeed run
let me know your thoughts we'll have the
clip of roger stone and trump at
mar-a-lago
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's uh talk a little
bit about radical republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
really the worst of the worst of
american politics if you imagine for a
second oh let's say we were sending some
elected officials to you know pick a
country wherever ireland to represent
the best of the united states house and
senate marjorie taylor green is
basically the most humiliating person
you could send along with a couple
others madison cawthorne louis gomer
lauren beaubert matt matt gates these
types of people okay so she's uh facing
some problems the first problem is that
a judge has ruled
that the effort to remove marjorie
taylor greene from her re-election
ballot in november uh upcoming now in a
few months
can go forward now the judge hasn't said
she's off the ballot the judge has said
the effort can in principle go forward
this is absolutely fascinating and this
is going to be a legal fight so let me
explain what's going on or or we're
going to look at the new york times
report from this morning a federal judge
cleared the way
for a group of georgia voters to move
forward with legal efforts seeking to
disqualify green
from running for re-election why well
citing her role in the trump riots the
disqualification effort is based on a
constitutional provision adopted after
the civil war that barred members of the
confederacy from holding office
it mirrors several other cases involving
republican members of congress whose
roles leading up to enduring the trump
riots have drawn criticism the judge was
appointed to the district court for the
northern district of georgia by
president barack obama
and denied marjorie taylor green's
request for a preliminary injunction and
temporary restraining order
um
in the 73-page ruling judge tottenberg
wrote that green had failed to meet the
burden of persuasion in her request for
injunctive relief this case involves a
whirlpool of colliding constitutional
interest of public import the novelty of
the factual and historical posture
especially assessed in the context of a
preliminary injunction motion has made
resolution of the complex legal issues
particularly demanding
um
the argument that green made is there's
no way to resolve this fully before the
primary on may 24th and absentee ballots
are going to start being mailed in on
april 25th so there's there's no way to
fully adjudicate this in time
and um
the argument from the judge here is
green is arguing sort of like procedure
like the the primaries really soon and
there's no way to decide this now the
judge determined green hasn't shown that
it's likely she would succeed on the
merits
so
she went but marjorie taylor green went
on tucker carlson's show last night
and she's flipping out listen to what
she had to say i have to protect myself
i have to go to court on friday and
actually be questioned about something
i've never been charged with and
something i was completely against and
so this is how far it's going these
leftists these progressives who would
rather want they'd rather have the judge
or bureaucrats making decisions instead
of voters they want to hand that over to
them and not let the people in my
district even have the right to vote for
me but no the republican party now
that's a very dishonest argument because
this is sort of like saying
hey you know um
uh
there's rules about who can be in the
house and senate and for example if a
member of the house were convicted of a
crime and then forced to resign
anybody could get up there and say you
know what
the right of the people to just decide
given that this individual was convicted
of a crime do we still want them
representing us or not that's being
denied to them right but these are the
rules these are the rules and the law is
you can move to have someone taken off
of a ballot
if you can prove that they did certain
things
that's all it it it's it's very naive or
cynical or just dishonest to say oh the
people aren't being allowed to just
voice their opinion well there are times
where we say you can't be on the ballot
it's to fight harder tucker you know
there's something that we that i have
learned and i think this is really
important you know if you can challenge
any representatives candidacy or
elective elected office holder then i
bet you we could round up some
republican voters who didn't like kamala
harris by the way still can't pronounce
kamala's name funding uh rioters
criminal rioters out of jail or ilhan
omar or corey bush or maxine waters now
what do those four women have in common
hold on a second kamala harris ilhan
omar corey bush maxine waters there's
something similar about them right i'm
trying to why why is she mentioning
those four exciting riots you know i
think there's there's another way to
play this game now of course
uh
this is also absurd what she says
because this is exactly what they did to
joe biden's win she said you can't just
have people challenge whatever anybody
anybody's position but joe biden won and
that's exactly what all of you guys did
you were like no he didn't win he
doesn't get to be there
there was no evidence for it there was
no legal basis there was no factual
basis there was no empirical basis so um
this is actually a very interesting
legal case
if this were to work against marjorie
taylor greene to keep her off the ballot
you in theory could use it against other
pro-insurrection pro-riot politicians
and i'm sure that if this goes against
marjorie taylor green she will try to
appeal and maybe it would get all the
way up to the supreme court because
they're actually i don't want to pretend
that the legal issue is cut and dry i
read a bunch of opinions this morning
and this comes down to the 14th
amendment so there is a constitutional
issue as to whether you really could
keep her off the ballot in this way
there's a mechanism to request it
and if it were
successful there would be a question as
to whether it's constitutional but
uh that doesn't matter it's a process
that is going through and her disdain
for having to participate in a legal
process aside from what your opinion is
of what the outcome should be is the
exact type of entitlement
that we've seen from these people for so
very long but this isn't the only
problem that marjorie taylor greene is
having let's go to the next one
marjorie taylor green
is in a very safe republican district in
georgia as a radical trumpist member of
the house of representatives but
for the first time
she spent more money than she raised
and
her democratic challenger raised more
money than she did
now i don't want to give anybody false
hope because she is in a very red
district but this is not particularly
good news for her
democratic challenger outraises marjorie
taylor green in georgia you really love
to see this democrat marcus flowers out
raised green in the first three months
of 2022 according to his latest federal
filings flowers an army veteran and
former military contractor pulled in
more than 2.4 million dollars in the
first quarter of 2022
dwarfing says the hill the fundraising
hall of green who raised under 1.1
million dollars in the exact same time
span
now importantly not only is it a very
safe republican district flowers is
behind green in cash on hand the latest
filings with the fec show green has 3
million in the bank flowers has 1.9
million and overall green has raised
about 8.4 million for her re-election
flowers is behind but not super far at
7.1 million for his campaign so far
unseating green is likely to be an
uphill battle for any democrat that is
absolutely true
but this may be a sign that there's an
appetite
for
rejecting
radical extremist cartoonish pathetic
pond scum trumpism which is what
marjorie taylor green represents yahoo
news reporting congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green's campaign committee goes
into the red for the first time clocking
up a fundraising deficit totaling 314
thousand dollars marjorie taylor green's
campaign committee reported its first
net loss since she was elected it spent
1.38 million in the first quarter of
2022
and banked 1.06 million in donations the
1.06 was rounded to 1.1 in the previous
article the spending included 140 000
for her security
and a retainer fee to trump lawyer john
eastman that's that wacky guy who's like
yeah mike pence just overturned the
entire thing
so
again the district is depending on where
you look
30 points in favor of a republican it
might only be 20 it might be 40 it
depends where you look but it is a
really really heavy republican district
i don't know how uh flowers wins
but
this could be a good sign
and it's also important to understand
that the incumbent effect is very real
and so even with the same fundraising
you would probably expect green to win
because the incumbency effect is very
real but that's also what makes the
fundraising numbers even more notable
for a non-incumbent in such a red
district to be
equally or even outraging the incumbent
republican it says a lot now of course a
lot of that money is coming from out of
the district
it's not a big shock that there are
people outside of
that georgia district who would love to
see marjorie taylor green removed
because she's such a lunatic and um just
holding the seat gives her an advantage
and
this is
not
likely the district
this is not likely to be a bellwether
district in november there are others
that are more likely to be what
bellwether districts were going to talk
about them but if we want to find
something good here it's that
this is a sort of celebrity republican
congresswoman
in a very red seat
and she lost net money spent more than
she took in in the first quarter of 2022
and her opponent who is not particularly
well known at least wasn't before this
election started
is able to keep up in fundraising it's a
great thing it would be great to knock
her out i'm not counting him out but we
just have to be realistic it's an
insanely republican skewed district
we'll take a quick break and be back
after this with with much more for you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
yesterday i came to you with the news
that alex jones infowars website has
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection and i said hey listen we've
got to be careful with this because it
seems that it is obviously a way
to he keep and hide money
from being subject to settlements
because the guy is being sued to high
heaven and it's not going well but it's
still interesting
he immediately after the bankruptcy went
public announced an emergency blowout
and i'm not talking about a diaper
blowout caused by all those weird
supplements that he takes i
i'm talking about an emergency blowout
sale
of these kooky products that he has on
his website so wasting absolutely no
time whatsoever here is alex jones big
announcement listen if you've not gotten
drinkable silver this would be a great
opportunity to do it you want us to be
able to stay on air
and be able to move forward in the
future i need you we don't really want
that that's the thing now
to not wait
and go to m4store.com especially those
of you that never bought a book never
bought a film never bought a t-shirt
never got a supplement imagine buying a
film from alex jones that is something
huh well man never got an infiltration
water filtration
shortwave radio thousands of great items
books you name it at infowarsstore.com
get your living defense get your
knockout it's back in stock uh bodies
ultimate turmeric formula lung cleanse
the lung cleanse there a there's a
product i would buy i actually was
thinking to myself
what could possibly be going on in
someone's life
where you go
to alex jones store
to get a lung cleanser i mean like what
if you fall for that you could fall for
anything
they're all there at infowarsstore.com
and it's just that simple there's also a
button up on the top
of the shopping cart that says support
and it says become a sponsor and you
just click there and you can give a
monthly donation or just give a one-time
donation and then we actually get 95 of
that money right instead of just you
know 30 or 40
50 with the sale of the product so
this is do or die time if you want to
keep us on air through the the these
attacks of the system and the system
pulling out all the stops you know the
crazy thing is like the mo i've never
met a genuine fan of alex jones i've met
people who watch his content because
it's so crazy and they're cur like we do
right i mean we kind of keep an eye on
what all of these extremists do i have
never met someone who seriously watches
alex jones out of silences then this is
the time they are trying to silence you
they're trying to take down the leading
voice
of
resistance
if alex jones is the leading voice of
resistance we're really in trouble uh
our good friend farin cousins
had a good tweet
with similar thoughts to mine from
yesterday about the entire bankruptcy
thing uh farron tweeted quote a lot of
people celebrating alex jones filing for
bankruptcy but that move just screws
over the victims and allows him to
shield money from them that they would
otherwise be able to go after
this move protects him and his money
and is not a good thing
farron going on to say the filing also
lets him restructure his business
holdings in order to keep operating
so the hatred and conspiracies aren't
going away so i don't trust the entire
bankruptcy thing any further than i'd be
able to throw alex jones i i don't it
just it stinks to high heaven like i
said yesterday and
there are lots of people celebrating it
and i mean listen you can be for speech
but for the failure of certain types of
speech right i mean this and this is
this is like an age-old battle and
debate
um for example
i used to interview these people from
the westboro baptist church and they
were the ones who would show up at
soldiers funerals with signs that would
say you know god hates these people and
those people
you know the people um i could recognize
that
they have a right to speak now
you know
there are different laws around
protesting at funerals and things like
that but let's generally just say
i recognize that people have a right to
express their opinion
but at the same time i can be thrilled
if their opinion is so unsavory
that they sort of like go out of
business and that's kind of what's
happened with the westboro baptist
church i'm not saying that they're
bankrupt but
they have become so out of favor where
even the small amount of interest that
there was in their message has
evaporated and they're nowhere now i
think that that's fantastic i'm not
against free speech because they're free
their speech is unpopular and similarly
there is absolutely no question
whatsoever that alex jones is allowed to
have a show
the government
shouldn't can't legally i mean they
shouldn't be censoring him platforms can
decide based on their terms of service
whether what alex jones does is or isn't
allowed
but it's okay to be happy if alex jones
particular speech is so distasteful
that it becomes financially uh inviable
not viable that that's a great thing i'm
i'm happy about that and it's not about
oh david do you do you wish that yeah my
alex jones impression right globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau mccrone
and the rest of these zio bish yeah it's
beautiful
okay
um
i think it's a great thing
if his speech is considered so
disgusting that he can't make money off
of it call me crazy i think that that's
a good thing
there's a guy named charles herbster
he's running for
uh state senate
and uh he's running for for senate well
what is he running for we're going to
figure out in a second he has been
accused of groping more than six women
and he has been very strongly endorsed
by donald trump vanity fair piece by
best levin
charles herbster insists he's the victim
of a smear campaign trying to destroy
him with lies
uh best levin writes donald trump isn't
great at a lot of stuff
but one thing he absolutely excels
excels at is endorsing horrible people
for office since 2016 a who's who of
trump-backed candidates has included roy
reportedly banned from the mall more
lauren i'll care my carry my glock to
congress bobert
herschel if evolution is real why do
apes still exist walker ron don't say
gay desantis mehmet have some snake oil
oz
matt human trafficking is fine gates and
mary hitler actually had a good idea
miller
in october a guy running for oh it's
nebraska governor named charles herbster
got himself added to the list
he has a habit of allegedly groping
women the nebraska examiner reported
thursday eight women say herbster groped
them
writing that six women said he touched
them inappropriately when they were
saying hello or goodbye or when posing
for a photograph by his side a seventh
accused the candidate of cornering her
in private and forcibly kissing her
all of the women told the outlet they
were intentionally grabbed not
inadvertently grazed in one particularly
gross incident republican state senator
julie slama said that herbster in the
middle of a crowded room at an event for
the douglas county republican party
reached up her skirt and touched her
inappropriately without her consent
these are allegations folks remember
another person who attended the event
confirmed they saw herbster reach up
slayma's skirt and claimed that he also
groped another woman's butt at the same
event at the same event
the nebraska examiner piece
is quite disturbing republican state
senator and seven other women say
charles herbster groped them he denies
the allegations now remember that
even if you think trump as a business
person is no good you don't like trump's
foreign policy you don't like trump's
views on immigration or whatever
his continued claim to fame and one
often cited by his strongest supporters
is he makes good choices with hiring he
hires the right people he hires the best
people
and
he continues to endorse people accused
of or proven to have said
horrible things
i encourage you to check out the
nebraska examiner article by aaron
sanderford it's very extensive it's very
detailed etc now the biggest frustration
i think that many of us are having at
this point
is that these types of allegations don't
matter
if the electorate that supports you
doesn't care about them or only cares
about them when they are allegations
against democrats and that's basically
what we have seen i mean at this point
i'm i'm curious to hear from people in
the audience
do allegations like this matter at all
anymore trump was accused
you know even the number is a hard
number to say trump was accused
very specifically of what we would call
sexual assault type behaviors by around
a dozen women but then subsequently we
learned about allegations of a more kind
of broader scope
from more than 40 women
and he talked about grab him by the
you-know-what and all these you just do
it and all these different things
and he was elected president in 2016. he
was he was really elected
uh we could say well part of it was
hillary wasn't a great candidate and
these different things but
the side that claims to be about family
values and all these things
has uh
not cared about it
when it's trump and they excuse it away
well hillary's worse or what am i going
to do stay home or those are lies it's
fake news all these different things so
does it even matter when their side is
accused of this stuff and we've also
talked before about how sometimes to
show how much not like them we are
the left sometimes goes overboard i
think the greatest example is the al
franken situation al franken
you know
he he took a distasteful picture
uh and it was inappropriate and it was
wrong and he apologized in all these
different things but immediately many
prominent democrats said al franken must
resign
and he did
and democrats lost what was a good
senator and i'm not defending what al
franken did but i'm pointing out the
scale of what he did is nothing compared
to what many of these republicans have
been accused of or have been proven to
have done
and
it may almost be a fault of the left
that it so quickly goes to we're not
going to be like them we're going to
clean house the same way they should be
cleaning house yeah but they're never
going to do it
and
i don't know
what the exact right balance is to find
but um
they don't seem to care about any of
this stuff and so there's a real
question as to how the left should
manage and react to it let me know your
thoughts i don't i don't i don't know
what the what the right strategy is
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p so yesterday a
guy from alabama
who said he doesn't know a lot of jews
uh he called in and he wanted me to
explain
yiddish words to him and the questions
were what is the diff what is schmeckle
and what's the difference between
schmeckle and shekel now the egg man
called in the egg man is a jewish man
and the egg man says it's wrong that
asking me jewish questions
is like asking a black woman to touch
her hair i don't know if this analogy is
exactly right but let's listen to what
the eggman had to say
hey dave the caller on today's show was
a schmuck um without using any yiddish
words and i'm just kidding
i really can't stand when people say to
me hey man did you do this hey did you
believe this that's like going up to a
black woman and saying hey can i touch
your hair
i mean i get it like when i was in
prison i'd meet guys from the south that
would say you're a jew where are your
horns okay i get that but it's not 25
years ago and we have the internet in
modern times now so i find it highly
insulting and i go back to my original
comment that caller is a schmuck for
asking you to speak for the jewish
language or the hebrew language or the
yiddish language shalom brother
yeah i don't know if i agree with the
egg man i mean like let's let's just
think it through
would it be crazy to think let's imagine
like a really spit what is a schmeckle
is is not exactly mainstream it's not
like hey
do do jews uh believe in the new
testament and it's like no okay so it's
it's schmeckles it's pretty pretty niche
let's say there was a discussion as to
which african countries were the main
sources of slaves brought to the united
states and let's say in a conversation
someone said
oh did uh
were there a lot of american slaves that
came from
the central african republic right
that's a really specific question i
don't know the answer to that
would it be wrong to wonder
if a black person in the group
might be more informed about that than i
am
i don't know i guess i'm not sure
i don't think the egg man is right that
asking me about yiddish words is the
same as asking to touch a black woman's
hair that there just seems to be
absolutely no comparison there but is it
reasonable to wonder
whether
based on an individual's identity you
might know more about a particular thing
i mean
you if you knew someone was a parent
i think it would be reasonable to go to
them with parenting questions over
someone who's not a parent
if you knew someone was tall
i don't think it's unreasonable to go to
them with questions about the day-to-day
of living while being tall
i i don't know i don't know that this is
that that crazy i think the real
critique is
you know about google right like if i
ever wonder about these questions you
just you just google it i don't know
that you need to leave me a voicemail
wait two weeks for me to get to that
voicemail and then give you an answer
but it is content so i don't know let me
know your thoughts we have an explosive
bonus show today there's not an
emergency blowout the way that alex
jones described earlier on the show but
we have a very explosive bonus show
today
a trump appointed judge has said
the cdc
exceeded its um uh jurisdiction
with the mask mandate on planes and the
judge ended the mass mandate on planes
yesterday pilots came out during flights
and announced to their uh passengers the
mask mandate is over they unmasked and
passengers cheered and unmasked and
immuno-compromised people on those
flights were horrified we're going to
talk about it we're going to talk about
it
also
j.d vance who i at one point thought hey
this is kind of like a reasonable
republican i was wrong
jd vance who is running for the ohio
senate seat has been endorsed by failed
former president donald trump we will
talk about jd vance
and thirdly elizabeth warren is now
targeting nancy pelosi
in a bid to avoid midterm losses for
democrats in november what
i will explain all of it to you on
today's bonus show you can access the
bonus show instantly by becoming a
member at joinpakman.com absolute last
thing it is finally that day it's almost
like christmas morning for our christian
viewers or
the fourth day of hanukkah for our
jewish years i always got the best gifts
on the fourth day that's why i was
always excited about day four
um
it is the day of the david pakman show
town hall the town hall will be live
today tuesday april 19
6 p.m eastern time we will be streaming
live on the pacman live youtube channel
and if you'd like to call in you can do
so through our discord davidpakman.com
discord if you're a member we will have
a priority line for you which is very
exciting and just another reason to get
yourself that membership at
joinpacman.com i will see everybody on
the bonus show today
on the town hall tonight or otherwise
sadly tomorrow on the next show